THERE'S ONLY SUCH YOU CAN TAKE.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOCILE AND
HUMBLE APPROACH AND NOT
[ BLEEP ].
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO CALL ME OUT
IN MY NAME, I'M GOING TO LOOK
THEM STRAIGHT IN THE EYE AND SEE
IF THEY'RE REALLY ABOUT IT.
MOST OF THE TIME THEY'RE NOT.
>> DO YOU THINK THE HOSTILITY
YOU GET.
>> THERE'S NO HOSTILITY, IT'S
BASKETBALL.
>> YOU WERE FLICKING SOME PEOPLE
OFF.
I ASSUME THERE'S SOME HOSTILITY.
>> ARE YOU GUESSING THERE'S
HOSTILITY?
>> YOU WERE RUNNING DOWN THE
FLOOR FLICKING PEOPLE OFF.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME YOU
CAUGHT IT.
IF YOU WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE FANS, GO ASK THEM.
>> DO YOU THINK THE ENERGY FROM
THE FANS YOU GET --
>> EMBRACE IT, EMBRACE IT.
IT'S DARK SIDE.
EMBRACE IT.
>> ARE WE GOING TO SPEND TIME
TALKING ABOUT --
>> IF YOU WANT TO.
>> FANS YELLING AT PLAYERS AND
PLAYERS REACTING AT FANS IN.
>> IT'S PART OF THE GAME.
I GREW UP IN TEXAS.
LOUISIANA.
IT'S PART OF THE GAME.
AND THE BEST THING CAN YOU DO IS
ONE, STAY A CONSUMMATE
PROFESSIONAL AND SEND THEIR ASS
HOME AT THE END OF THE SERIES.
THAT'S BEST THING YOU DO.
>> WHAT DOES REMAINING A
CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL IN THE
MOMENT MEAN TO YOU?
>> I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
BILL RUSSELL.
AND HE TOLD ME SOME THINGS I
NEVER KNEW AND THE THINGS THEY
HAD TO GO THROUGH.
AND HE PERSEVERED AND BECAME ONE
OF THE BEST BIG MEN, THAT'S THE
TYPE OF PROFESSIONAL I WANT TO
BE.
MOHAMMAD ALI, KAREEM, JACKIE
ROBINSON, ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
MADE IT, PAVED THE WAY FOR US TO
BE UP HERE NOW, THEY STAYED
PROFESSIONAL.
THEY HAD TO GO THROUGH SOME REAL
STUFF.
>> DOES THAT MEAN YOU DON'T
REACT?
>> NO, I REACT ON THE COURT,
SEND THEM HOME.
YOU DON'T WINE AND CRY ABOUT IT.
BOSTON, PHILLY, NEW YORK, THEY
DON'T CARE ANYWAY.
GAME TWO, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DOING MORE, THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THAT IN BOSTON.
JUST PLAY AND WIN GAMES, LIKE HE
SAID, IT'S JUST BASKETBALL.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ALL THAT
EITHER.
FANS, LISTEN.
95% OF THE FANS ARE AMAZING.
5%, YOU CAN TAKE THEM OUT BACK
AND I'D BEAT THE HELL OUT OF
THEM.
I'VE SAID THAT FOR 30 YEAR.
BUT THAT'S ONLY 5%.
MOST OF THE FANS ARE GREAT.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
CRAP HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BEST
BASKETBALL GAMES I'VE SEEN IN A
LONG TIME.
KENNY TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER.
EVERYBODY ON THAT COURT CAN
SLEEP GOOD TONIGHT, BECAUSE
EVERYBODY COMPETED, CO